what the heck are you doing Trevor
nothing to nothing too crazy just trying
to have fun playing the game just trying
to go out there and win games and you
know that's uh that's been my approach
so for how surprised are you um I can't
lie um I'm pretty surprised um you know
if you told me I was gonna do that oh
I'd say I wouldn't believe you but um
yeah it's just it's pretty surprising
but um you know I know that another I
was capable of doing something like that
do you have four hits on the season and
all four home runs you don't have
anything else yeah that's right but
you're you weren't a home run hitter in
the minors what was the most you had 20
in the minors 20 yeah that's right okay
so have you added more power since you
got to the major leagues um I don't know
I guess we'll we'll see over time but um
yeah I feel like um you know as a source
stop i hit a good amount of home runs in
the minor leagues for a shortstop but um
yeah I mean that that's not necessarily
the main focus in my game is to hit home
runs um yeah I in the past I've had a
lot of doubles and you know drove the
ball pretty well but um yeah I haven't
seen the home runs and it at this pace
but um yeah it's a it's a little crazy
right now you hit two home runs off
Santa cranky that doesn't happen Trevor
yeah yeah he's a great pitcher he's um
you know he's one of the best but um
yeah i mean i don't know it's just kind
of one of those weird things I kind of
just saw a couple because I liked and
put my swing on it what's the clubhouse
like or but the dugout when you come
back after doing that um everybody's
pretty fired up it's um it's exciting
it's fun to you know be a part of that
and it's it's cool for me to see all the
guys you know kind of take me in and you
know welcome in and that that kind of
fashion you know I can tell that they're
very excited but yeah it's just um no
it's fun right now you get recognized on
the street no not yet not yet and and
they have they hazed you yet your
teammates um no nothing nothing too
crazy yeah it's coming you know I yeah I
know I know it's coming so I'm hanging
in there but yeah I all I've had to do
really is just kind of carry Mark
Reynolds bat and glove around a few
times but nothing crazy he should be
carrying yours Trevor and now uh who is
our up and do that how did you look up
to in baseball growing up I really loved
watching Derek Jeter he was he was my
favorite player and I really loves
watching him and Cal Ripken junior and
ken griffey jr. what was your best sport
in high school best sport yeah baseball
yeah baseball for sure but you were good
in basketball and football as well
yeah was um you know I love flying all
three sports football was football was
fun too until I broke my collarbone and
I was kind of over that were you a
quarterback oh yeah that's right i was
no who what kind of quarterback were you
who would you compare your your
abilities to or the style oh oh let's
see um i would say Russell Wilson I
guess because I like to get out of the
pocket and run it a little bit too and
that's how you got your collarbone
broken yeah exactly does the ball carry
differently in Colorado um you know I
can't say for sure from experience
because I've never I've never taken BP
here played baseball here so from what I
hear it it flies a little a little
better so i guess today we have a
workout and we'll be out there on the
field I can kind of know for sure you uh
you're on a pace for 216 home runs this
year Trevor just to let you know yeah I
don't know about that I don't think
you're going to get to 216 but I got you
I got you at UH 25 this year yeah 216 is
probably a far stretch but yeah I don't
I don't have personal goal myself for
home runs um but yeah what you said
sounds good yeah 25 is good right you'll
pencil pencil you in for that don't be
afraid to get a base hit here on Friday
against the Padres Trevor yeah I'll keep
that in mind I'll try and did you get
the the first ball back that you hit
your first hit the majors uh you know
obviously a home run but you did you get
the baseball
yes we got it back I think one of the
fans tried to throw it back and i think
it was um i think it was one of the it
was a BP ball that they threw back and
they tried to keep the other one I think
and then oh we could tell because it
didn't have the right riding on it I
don't think it said opening day on it so
hmm we figured it out and we got it back
so Alexa good there I'll leave you with
this it took Derek Jeter 66 games to hit
his first three home runs in the major
leagues so you're already doing
something better than Derek Jeter did oh
that's uh any time something like that
happens and Jeter's mentioned and I'm
all for it but um have fun with I don't
ever have fun with it I know I will it's
uncomfortable talking about you know
because it's new and you don't want to
sound cocky but you did something that
hasn't been done in over a hundred years
so enjoy it have fun and because as you
know you know when the pitchers get get
ahold of you the second time around
that's when the game really begins yeah
that's right but thanks for joining us
and congratulations again alrighty thank
you yeah that's Trevor story Rockies
rookie shortstop the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience